bill good evening Congress does not have
much power to stop President Trump's new
tariff proposal so the focus right now
is on asking him to fine-tune it the
smarter way to go is to make it more
surgical and more targeted speaker
Ryan's comments reflect conservatives
heartburn on Capitol Hill over president
Trump's proposed tariffs on aluminum and
steel and their concerns of a possible
trade war we want to make sure that
abusers are held to account especially
China with when it comes to dumping and
trans shipping but we also want to make
sure that every step we take forward
does not create any unintended
consequences Republicans are eager to
run this year on passing tax reform and
they worried new tariffs could have a
negative impact on gains in the economy
there is a lot of concern among
Republican senators that this could sort
of metastasize into a larger trade war
Senate Democratic leader Chuck Schumer
says the action should be focused on
Beijing the president's instincts to go
after China are the right thing to do I
think China has taken terrible advantage
of America over the last decade or two
and they don't play fair Ohio Republican
Senator Rob Portman is a former US Trade
Representative it ought to be focused on
particular products in particular
countries and not be so broad-based we
ought to use more of a scalpel approach
and I think that would be better for our
economy today Treasury secretary Steve
minuchin doubled down on president
Trump's indication that there could be
fine-tuning for neighboring trade
partners to the extent that were
successful in renegotiating NAFTA those
those tariffs won't apply to Mexico and
Canada some outside conservative allies
warned in a letter to the president
today quote a new tax on steel and
aluminum will cost jobs increased cost
to consumers and forced businesses to go
overseas we strongly urge you to
reconsider this proposal some are
hopeful that pushback from outside
groups and the markets will help get the
attention of those at the White House if
the president does not listen to his
fellow Republicans here in Congress